l'allemand notre invité joël mêlant lé
député est reine ou parlement européen
merci veulent maintenant d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors
énorme dispositif policier pourquoi
pourquoi parce que depuis maintenant
deux ans et demi à l'occasion de lutte
parfaitement légitime comme celle d'elie
gilet jaune et même aujourd'hui on peut
le penser de revendications multiples
face aux conséquences actuelles et à
venir de la crise du coc vide viennent
s'ajouter en deuxième partie de
manifestations des personnes qui sont
pas du tout dans cette notion là
d'abord je ne suis pas sûr que tous ces
gens là travaillent et puis leurs
intérêts ne sont pas du tout ceux de
construire une société
il sonde à s'attaquer à certains
symboles de cette société mais on
pourrait dire que leur jeune âge peut
leur faire penser à des utopies mais en
tout cas pas à ce prix là est en tout
cas ce n'est pas à nos forces de l'ordre
dé ensuite de se trouver dans des
situations impossibles parce que si elle
elle respecte nos forces de l'ordre
respecte les manifestants autant que la
mesure les autorise bien entendu autant
les manifestants ne les respectent plus
et là on est dans un système de chaos
la répétition une nouvelle fois de ses
scènes va finir d'exaspérer les français
qui vraiment autre chose à faire que de
voir des spectacles comme celui là
évidemment alors un 1er mai en pleine
période de crise sanitaire
vous êtes député vous est également
médecin j'imagine que vous portez un
regard particulier sur cette pandémie à
bien cette pandémie et les elle est
d'abord tout à fait unique
on a beaucoup beaucoup de mal à trouver
des repères et des référentiels et il
est sûr que d'avoir une manifestation
comme aujourd'hui avec des contacts
aussi rapproché moi je regarde notre
image à l'instant bien que deux
personnes en un masque et mettre ainsi
en danger toute personne qui serait dans
un système de nombreux comment dirais-je
de non respect des distances iations est
insupportable évidemment alors les
revendications oui d'autant plus que les
indication d'aujourd'hui par rapport aux
problèmes qu'il y avait à deux ans et
demi pour les jets les jaunes rien n'a
été réglé on est bien d'accord tous les
problèmes sanitaires qui se posent ils
vont être encore avec nous quelques
temps mais on sait aussi que la sortie
de crise va être tout à fait
extraordinaire et que du point de vue
social et du point de vue financier au
point de l'emploi on va avoir des une
situation très difficile à gérer
donc c'est pas le moment d'assister à
des scènes de chaos c'est le moment
d'arriver à trouver des solutions
et bien évidemment il faut que ce soit
par des personnes raisonnables pas
tomber sous le joug de de casseurs de
black blocks de personnes qui ont
intérêt à installer une société de chaos
bien évidemment alors en défilé 1 pour
le premier mais en quoi ce 1er mai est
il différent des années précédentes
il est différent au sens où il y as
c'est la première fois qu'on peut avoir
des ressortir dans la rue depuis
maintenant pas mal de temps l'an dernier
ça a été beaucoup plus compliquée et il
est différent parce que effectivement
les inquiétudes des français sont au
maximum il inquiétudes des français ne
sont pas du tout celles de cette poignée
de personnes qui casse dans les rues
neil l inquiétude des français ce sont
celles les problèmes sanitaires déjà le
problème de tous ceux qui ont été
touchés par la maladie ou qui ont perdu
quelqu'un atteint même 100 mille
personnes qui sont parties cette année
donc c'est plus de cent mille familles
qui ont été touchés c'est aussi des
problèmes de revenus permanents et on
sait qu'actuellement beaucoup beaucoup
de corps de métier je pense aux artisans
tpe pme le restaurateur n'est pas mais
on sait aussi l'étape s'y met aussi
et toutes sortes de métiers qui vivent
de ces filières de qui sont actuellement
fermés je pense aussi aux agriculteurs
pratiquement tout le monde est touché
actuellement donc tout le monde a des
inquiétudes qui sont des inquiétudes de
pouvoir boucler les fins de mois est
assurée demain est assurée demain on
voit très bien que ça va être assez
compliqué on ne sait pas du tout avec
l'argent qui a été dépensé le quoi qu'il
en coûte
on ne sait pas du tout comment nous
pourrons retomber sur nos pieds alors
que la situation économique de la france
était déjà relativement fragile vous
êtes député au parlement européen vais
donc vous parler du plan de relance 1
qui a été adopté
vous savez un regard portez-vous
justement sur ce plan de relance et la
rapidité relatives à laquelle arrive des
fois c'est un plan de relance qui déjà
en a profité pour cible et non pas
l'emploi ni le niveau social des gens ni
la reprise économique des tpe pme mais
il a ciblé à plus de 30 à 40%
l'environnement alors oui d'accord pour
l'environnement mais pas non plus à
n'importe quel prix il ya des urgences
qui sont autres que celles de mètre du
green deal partout de tous verdir donc
ce plan de relance il était déjà
relativement biaisée de la même façon
d'ailleurs que le plan de relance
national et tous les plans de relance
nationaux et bien évidemment la machine
européenne est beaucoup trop lourde
et quand on sait que l'allemagne freine
un peu sa mise en application
on se dit que ce sont des sommes très
importantes qui là aussi sont payés
quand même d'une certaine manière un peu
sûr pas du crédit en tant que tel mais
sur des investissements nécessaires dont
on n'est pas sûr d'avoir encore la
totalité de la somme vous parliez
d'urgence telles sont elles aujourd'hui
pour la france
les urgences voyait déjà il ya l'urgence
sanitaire il est urgent urgent urgent
d'en sortir enfin c'est ce sont des
mômes il faut mettre des actes avec je
crois qu'il faut que tout le monde
prenne la condition la connaissance et
la conscience que nous sommes dans un
phénomène jamais connu avec un virus
pour ne connaît pas on en connaît
toujours pas l'origine je n'arrête pas
de le dire et qui a des caractéristiques
elles aussi tout à fait inconnu donc
j'entends bien que tout le monde en ait
assez évidemment envie de respirer mais
il faut quand même regarder que ça prend
des proportions pour lesquelles on a de
moins en moins la main avec des
gouvernements comme celui de monsieur
matheron qui fait tout en par petites
bribes à contretemps en désordre et fait
en sorte de lasser les personnes qui de
qui pourrait encore pouvoir tenir le
coup en étant citoyens et en tenant les
mesures barrières et toutes ces mesures
qui ont été mises en place évidemment
qu'on n'y arrive plus donc l'urgence
c'est l'urgence sanitaire mais aussi des
urgences économiques
mais tout cela ne peut se faire et se
mettre en place que quand on aura
complètement verrouillé cette crise et
que nous aurons installer des
coopérations
d'autres pays dans le monde pas
forcément à partir de l'union européenne
et ses sculptures qui sont trop lourdes
mais que nous arrivions à nous mettre
d'accord et harmoniser un système de
lutte contre cette épidémie alors un
défilé avec beaucoup de revendications
sociales il y en a une plus ou moins
emblématiques la récente de l'assurance
chômage que les manifestants dénoncent
aujourd'hui
y at il vraiment une chance que le
gouvernement fasse marche arrière sur
cette question je ne pense pas la façon
de fonctionner de monsieur macro et est
tout à fait étonnante il est hors du
temps il ya deux caractéristiques la
première c'est qu'il ne revient jamais
sur ce qu'il a dit mais ça c'est le
propre des gens qui se croient
intelligents et la deuxième c'est que
pardonnez moi l'expression gym
sauf qu'il est un peu gauche et dès
demain c'est à dire que tout ce qui
touche il le casse et on peut pas
remonter quelque chose derrière d'une
manière aisée évidemment qu'avec la
situation du pô vide et cette
pérennisation de cette crise pour
laquelle il est pour beaucoup nous
verrons quand nous ferons le point dans
quelques mois c'est lui qui à chaque
étape à rater les bonnes décisions
le plan chômage tel qu'il a été prévu
est totalement obsolète il faut tout
remettre à plat fait aussi des
projections en même temps nous avons
quand même deux problèmes
c'était peu avant cette crise la
situation économique et de l'emploi
était déjà très fragile on n'avait pas
encore récupéré le niveau de 2008 mais
aussi nous nous trouvons à un carrefour
de changement de paradigme ce qu'on
appelle des possibilités de travail
c'est à dire que le tout ce qui est
numérique toutes les plateformes tout la
robotisation l'intelligence artificielle
vent on le sait mettre au chômage
énormément de personnes donc ce plan de
match on est totalement obsolète il faut
en urgence
prévoir un plan réaliste pour rapidement
et dans les mois et les années qui
viennent sinon on perdra une génération
qui n'aura plus la possibilité de
retourner au travail ça veut dire
prendre comme le plan de relance
actuellement d'ailleurs
l'exécutif français parlent du deuxième
plan de relance
ça veut dire que pour vous il est
obsolète inutiles qui ne va pas dans la
bonne direction
il est mal conçu si vous voulez il est
pas réalistes face à la situation que
nous avons qui est des armes snort je
veux dire que quiconque de pouvoir
aurait des grandes difficultés à gérer à
s'agit pas de critiquer pour critiquer
mais nous avons une situation qui depuis
maintenant 18 mois est totalement
inattendu mais nous aurions quand même
dû envisager l'emploi au regard des
modifications de société que sont les
plateformes le e-commerce l'intelligence
artificielle y avait duré déjà eu des
difficultés au regard de l'emploi du
chômage
mais qui dit aussi emploi chômage dit
cotisations sociales dit donc sans teddy
donc famille et surtout retraite les
inquiétudes
là elles sont aussi très importantes
chez nos retraités qui eux ne savent
plus véritablement s'ils vont pouvoir
avoir une sécurité de leurs revenus
et comment va-t-on assurer leur
dépendance
nous sommes dans une situation où il
faut être véritablement comment dire
être très très lucide et vais mettre à
plat tous les éléments qui nous
permettront de sortir avec le minimum de
casse de cette situation sinon nous
n'assurerons aucun des comptes sociaux
et du coup la colère du gilet jaune
elle sera encore plus justifié la colère
des taxes il des bars des restaurants de
tous les retraités de tous les vivres
libéraux de tous les tpe pme vont être
encore plus justifié
il faut vraiment qu'on se reprenne et
qu'on soit dans la simplicité la clarté
et non pas des plans établis par
quelques fonctionnaires à bercy une dans
un cabinet ministériel
joëlle mélin merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous rappelle que vous êtes député
rnd au parlement européen
merci